bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france à voir comment les
groupes terroristes arrivent à
s'implanter dans des pays par exemple
comme la république démocratique du
congo ou le mozambique est ce que c'est
parce qu'ils profitent des insurrections
locale il s'adapte et essayer de percer
et dé découvrir les faiblesses de ces
états on a très bien remarqué que depuis
le début de l'engagement des forces des
différentes forces armées africaines
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme les
aime les armées africaines n'étaient pas
préparés et ils sont insuffisamment armé
pour affronter cette nouvelle menace
les armées africaines étaient préparés à
des conflits entre états n'étaient pas
préparés à des conflits asymétriques
contre le jihadiste la deuxième raison
est cause de cette prolifération de
cette nouvelle stratégie de ces
djihadistes d'attaquer la fiq sur
différents fronts parce qu'il n'existe
pas un plan africain de lutte contre le
terrorisme qui peut être appliqué dans
tous les pays africains
quand on voit au niveau du sahel maghreb
afrique de l'est d'afrique australe
chaque région de l'afrique c'est bas
avec ses propres moyens et ses propres
stratégies
alors que la menace est universelle et
une menace commune la troisième raison
est cause c'est sûr la fiq est le pays
de son incapacité à contrôler la
circulation des armes à contrôler les
différentes ressources que ces
terroristes cherchent à pour avoir pour
s'équiper pour cerner et pour acheter
justement on paie les différentes
personnes qui le recrute
l'afrique est devenue un terreau fertile
pour cette organisation
parce que l'afrique n'était pas préparés
à les affronter alors on sait que
l'absence de l'état dans certains pays
la vulnérabilité des populations locales
ça constitue un terreau idéal pour les
terroristes mais ce n'est pas vraiment
un phénomène nouveau qu'est ce qui a
changé sept dernières années
rien n'a changé madame l'afrique est
toujours
comme elle était la fille naïve
intégration c'est un problème
transnationales transversale aujourd'hui
les terroristes circule entre les
différents états pour mepi justement des
frontières on met plus de contrôle
aujourd'hui quand des touristes à l'est
du mali jusqu'au abidjan en côte
d'ivoire
vous voyez donc ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui si la côte d'ivoire le
burkina le mali n'ont pas une stratégie
commune intégrée de pouvoir ce combat de
ce phénomène si chacun est cantonné dans
100 pays et sa région avec sa stratégie
et justement ces états ne pourront pas
nous avons vu malgré ses réponses
militaires avec l'appui de la communauté
internationale de l'onu et même de
l'union européenne
on va très bien qu'aujourd'hui depuis
dix ans c'est pratiquement le chien on y
arrive et même au point que même la face
décide de retirer ses courses barkan
dont la réponse aujourd'hui à dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme est une
réponse globale
elle doit être inclusif afin de pouvoir
combattre ces régimes
le contrôle de la circulation des armes
le contrôle même aujourd'hui des huit
cas saharienne commence et russie feront
pas ce qu'ils sont en train de se battre
pour contrôler ces routes parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est là où passent les
trafics de drogue et le trafic de
contrôle du trafic de drogue
c'est une source de financement pour le
terroriste de cette auris aujourd'hui
sont en train de profiter de sa
faiblesse des états mais aussi de ses
faiblesses la pauvreté de l'afrique
parce qu'aujourd'hui tout le pouvoir
recruter de jeunes pour qu'ils croient à
leur idéologie et bien faut que ces
jeunes soient dans une situation
économique ou une détresse économique
quelle puce
aujourd'hui s'offrira c'est à cette
théorie cela donc l'état à doit répondre
militairement la communauté
internationale drogue le panneau
mitterrand mais l'aspect économique et
social doivent aussi prévaloir pour
pouvoir convaincre sensibiliser sa
population africaine à pouvoir
participer eux aussi à leur manière à la
lutte contre le terrorisme en essayant
d'éviter ces dix ans dr humain et ses
recrutements massifs de la jeunesse
africaine dans ce public et à quel point
l'actuelle pandémie ans le co vite 19
at-il fragiliser la situation dans
certains pays africains
la situation du communisme a aggravé la
situation dans le sens où
les états africains n'avaient pas le
moyen de répondre à cette pandémie
ces demandes des moyens de favoriser
augmente justement la vulnérabilité de
ces populations
face à cette vague de terrorisme qui
existe six essais ces états ont répondu
comme il faut eh bien ces personnes
vulnérables quand on dit la
vulnérabilité de la population va dans
le sens où ils sont capables d'être
recruté très facilement ou bien des
cours à cette idéologie ou des foyers
des touristes puissent s'installer dans
des villages très éloignées coupé de
l'état et qui n'a aucune réponse
aujourd'hui on a vu que cette horreur et
se sont en train de profiter de cette
faiblesse pour pouvoir remplacer l'état
en ayant des moyens social économique
pour pouvoir tourner à ces populations
pour leur montrer que c'est mieux de les
suivre que tu veux de l'état dont
l'absence de ses moyens percutant des
réponses adéquates pour pouvoir
combattre ces terroristes et occuper le
terrain l'absence de l'état est le plus
gros problème est la plus grande cause
de l'avancement ou même dès
l'implantation de ces terroristes à
travers la fin de laquelle m yakubu
koundougou me merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france